we continue to monitor the situation and
coordinate actions to respond to putin's
terrible illegal invasion
today canada is imposing 14 uh new
restrictions on 14 close associates of
the russian regime including
vladimir putin's two adult daughters as
well as oligarchs and their family
members
this russian regime and its associates
need to continue to be held accountable
for their actions
we know and unfortunately even as russia
has pulled back from kiev
it is intensifying its uh attacks on the
donbass
ukrainians have uh fought like heroes
over the past number of months and
they're not just fighting for ukraine
they're fighting for the values that
underpin so many of our free democratic
societies which is why the world needs
to continue to step up why canada is
continuing to stand with ukraine to
stand against russia
but also ensure that this
conflict doesn't escalate to elsewhere
so our support for ukraine has been
financial in that we continue to uh
clear up uh billions of dollars in funds
to help ukraine continue to operate
while at the same time supporting them
we've stepped up with military aid both
non-lethal and lethal and of course
we're there with humanitarian aid over
the past weeks we've been in close
contact with president zielenski
since the very beginning and we're very
responsive to what it is that they need
most specifically their most recent
request from canada is to help them with
heavy artillery because that's what uh
the phase of the war is in right now uh
and canada uh will be uh sending heavy
artillery to ukraine uh with more
details to come in the coming days but
we will continue to stand with ukraine
and stand for the values that underpin
all of our free societies